this is a meter he's Venezuelan and
seeking asylum in Spain earlier this
year Amador fled his home country and
arrived in Madrid he told us his story
suffered political persecution for
marching for protesting for being in
complete opposition to what's happening
at the moment I was threatened harassed
and robbed I left because I got sick and
also because of the political issues I
tried to stay in my home in my country
with my people
Emira arrived in Spain on a tourist visa
and didn't seek asylum upon arrival he
instead waited for five months I was
scared I asked about how asylum worked
what would come of it and what I
wouldn't be able to do what always
happens is they take your passport from
you you can't leave the country and you
don't know how long the process takes
you don't know what Pandora's box it
will open so it was for those reasons I
decided to take the time and seek
political asylum Spain's interior
ministry turned down our request for an
interview but official figures for 2017
have shown the vast majority of asylum
applications made by Venezuelans in
Spain were rejected or simply not
processed due to a large backlog of
applicants over twelve thousand
Venezuelans have sought asylum so far
this year here in Spain for various
cultural linguistic historical and
family reasons Spain is the number one
EU destination for Venezuelans fleeing
their country mario says who's better of
the United Nations refugee agency
explained the reality of the asylum
application process in Spain there are
cases of people waiting one or two years
and that includes Venezuelans one
process to stay in the country must be
cancelled or closed before another can
begin one person who's been in Spain
seeking international protection who's
been seeking asylum for two or three
years can then include
time in other processes for immigrants
to legalize themselves they can use it
to prove they have settled in Spain or
seek Spanish nationality
Lanna finale de Fora Mira
the legal limbo has been difficult but
he remains positive about his new life
in Madrid I don't know what's going to
happen sometimes I feel positive
sometimes I feel down sometimes I really
want to push forward but other times I
feel like I want to give up I sometimes
think of giving up my asylum application
but like everyone I have dreams I want
to come true I have goals and I think
Spain can allow me to achieve them
perhaps a small glimmer of hope for the
increasing number of Venezuelans seeking
asylum in Spain